vielleicht noch eine frage zu dem was
gerade hier läuft auf dem parteitag
sozialpolitik da sich die afg ja auch
nicht einig dass er in die
wirtschaftsliberale mehr in die sozial
patriotische nennen sie ist sozusagen
sozial nationalistische richtung gehen
wird es war eine das ist eine ein zitat
aus einer auf einen presseartikel sozial
nationalistische stört sozial aber das
meinen sie jetzt wirklich nicht nein das
ist ein zitat manche sagen das sei ihre
politischen gegner das sei soziale
nationalistisch was man da sagt doch
nicht zu eigen machen habe es zitiert
ich habe es mir nicht zu eigen gemacht
und ich habe es zitiert in welche
richtung soll es dann gehen was wird
sich durchsetzen auf diesem parteitag
welche richtung das ist ein ganz ganz
ehrlich
also so eine art der fragestellung auch
wenn sie es nur zur nur zitieren die
lehne ich ab
ich muss ihnen ganz ehrlich sagen das
was sie hier gerade mich gefragt haben
ob ihr etwas national soziale oder
nationalsozialistischer ist eine
unverschämtheit und ich überhaupt gar
nicht unseren leitantrag gelesen haben
der sich mit dieser sozial politik
beschäftigt es ist ein kompromiss
zwischen ein mischsystem in der
sozialpolitik zwischen
umlagefinanzierung kapitaldeckung und
wirklich diese fragestellung halte ich
für unseriös und ich unterhalte mich
gerne mal weiter als den vielleicht dass
manche soziale deutsche startet wie sie
sie normalerweise ich halte das für
unseriös die art der fragestellung wie
sie mir gerade wie sie mir gerade
gefragt
das knie hat aus einer haltung fertig
nationalsozialisten habe ich nicht
gesagt doch nach sozial noch günstig war
etwas anderes
gut dann hat frau weiter jetzt denn das
interview mit phoenix früher verlassen
das ist glaube ich nicht das erste
interview das alles weiterführt und
vorzeitig beendet wir werden aber schon
fast am ende gewesen ja soweit das
interview mit der fraktionschefin der
fdp im bundestag alle zweifel und